[Musik]
sarah lisa hat mir gesagt dass der bald
geburtstag hat selber eine freundin von
mir ich möchte etwas schenken
aha ich möchte ihren fahrrad schenken
was das kannst du dir doch gar nicht
leisten
es muss ja auch kein neues fahrzeug du
meinst ein gebrauchtes ja ich schenk dir
ein gebrauchtes fahrrad das ist dabei
immer noch ziemlich teuer für ein
geburtstagsgeschenk
ich möchte selber überraschen das ist
wirklich nett von dir aber du solltest
vielleicht mehr zeit mit der suche nach
einer arbeit verbringen mach dir keine
sorgen ich finde mal etwas bestimmt bis
dahin musst du deine freundin ihren
preis wert der geschenke kaufen bittet
jara du kannst doch bestimmt eine
gebrauchtes fahrrad finden ich zahle dir
das geld auch so schnell wie möglich
zurück wenn es denn der geburtstag bald
ich finde es heute noch heraus
[Musik]
und jetzt packt mit an